[Music]
signs are usually not the most exciting
things they tell you when to stop when
you can go when to yield nothing too
interesting but every once in a while
you come across a sign that is so
strange
it had to be created on accident signs
so outrageous that they probably
shouldn't even be seen by children could
you believe a bad translation turn to
sign into something really inappropriate
stay tuned to see how if this is your
first time visiting our channel don't
forget to subscribe and give this video
a big thumbs up today we're sharing top
10 accidentally inappropriate signs
Church violators church signs are
probably the last thing you would think
could be funny but when this one church
had a misplaced modifier or two and no
punctuation hilarity ensued Clifton
Baptist Church based out of Louisville
Kentucky simply intended to post a sign
discouraging non churchgoers from taking
up their parking spaces what they got
was a viral photo that had been posted
everywhere from Reader's Digest to
Pinterest the sign read church parking
only violators will be baptized Bazaar
Church signs are nothing new from church
signs that read I wish Noah had swatted
those two mosquitos too hipster Jesus
loved you before you are cool churches
have been infusing their monikers with
more humor as of recent years the fad
has become so big that numerous new
sites have dedicated articles to the top
strangest or funniest signs planted in
front of churches the humorous signs
have become a way to make churches seem
friendlier and draw in larger crowds
after all if your church goes viral you
can expect to see a larger crowd come
next Sunday what are some of the
craziest church signs you've seen
man-eating insects that you never
thought you'd see a sign warning of
giant man-eating mosquitos amidst all of
the stop and no left turn signs well if
you are heading south in Alaska you may
just see one this sign was just one in a
series that the Grandin Alley Lodge put
up to make sure drivers were paying
attention as they made their way to the
hotel
we've heard of rolling your window down
or
lasting the AC to combat sleepiness on
the road but never creating ridiculous
roadsides
some of the others included notices like
aware of falling coconuts watch for
aircraft and freeway ends the
treacherous road that leads up to
Sugarloaf Mountain is so steep that it
is imperative for drivers to pay
attention the signs were installed over
the course of four or five years
according to general manager of the
Grandin alley Lodge Joe Merrill the
signs were proposed by Dennis Brandon a
marketing consultant for the hotel the
manager said that the collection had
been added to each year the ideas for
the signs now come out of different
people's knife well that's one way to
stay awake and safe nude sunbathers
eating waffles nude beaches have become
all the rage in recent years it would
make sense to have signs that let
beachgoers know when they are
approaching such a location while these
nude people are taking it one step
further so you must be warned you may
see them eating waffles nude nude
beaches are quite common around Europe
but Beach is dedicated to sweet
breakfast food consumption are a whole
new thing since its first appearance
this sign has become an internet
sensation and has been posted everywhere
from Pinterest to read it many reddit
users commented and why the nude beach
goers had chosen waffles over pancakes
and a war of breakfast pastries ensued
times like this are completely necessary
due to laws that prohibit nudity in
public in fact in recent years the laws
against indecent exposure have become
more strict in the u.s. there are no
overarching laws against public nudity
as it is up to each state to determine
what happens to nudists in most states
however public nudity isn't limited to
the public if a person is on private
property but is viewable from a public
space they can get charged as well let's
just hope they aren't eating waffles
only use the toilet
some signs are necessary like traffic
signs wet floor signs and anything that
alerts someone of danger sometimes you
think would be rather self-explanatory
but that would be giving people much
more credit than it's due this
particular sign reads for sanitary
please do not use this trashcan as a
toilet please use the toilet only this
sign makes you wonder why on earth would
anyone need to be told not to poop in a
trash can
shouldn't it be pretty obvious that a
trashcan is for just that trash actually
it's not that obvious pooping in the
trashcan has caused some of the most
sensationalized lawsuits in history in
one popular case a woman had to go to
court with ESPN because of her continual
pooping in the work trashcan the case
went on for quite some time with a
company being forced to site times that
this woman defecated in their trash can
perhaps all of this could have been
avoided with a simple sign asking
employees to please not use the trashcan
as a toilet we bet whoever hung up the
sign never had to worry about this again
caution
tapirs spray what are some signs that
you would expect to see at the zoo signs
like caution don't feed the animals or
one telling you not to stick your hand
inside the fence are commonplace don't
raise any eyebrows but beware of urine
does not typically fall in the line of
ordinary signs well that is except for
when it comes to tapers native to South
America and Asia tapers are known to
urinate frequently in the evening the
catch is that due to their structure
they typically urinate backward and the
spray can reach several feet for this
reason among others tapirs are rarely
found in zoos or public areas they are
very shy and will freeze when they sense
people around though they don't like to
be around people
tapirs are known for spraying their
piece so you can never be too far away
on lookers 7 to 10 feet away may still
be at risk of getting sprayed on so
while a sign like this may seem
ridiculous and a little outrageous it's
actually quite necessary in any area
where tapers are around next time you
happen to be around a tapir make sure
you cover your eyes hide your potato
Pranksters are all around us they take
normal things and inject them with a
dose of hilarity where would we be
without them sometimes the funniest
signs come from a collaboration and
that's exactly what happened with this
one when pranksters get involved even a
I meant to inform people of ducks
crossing can be transformed into a
completely different message in this
instance a perfectly normal sign
reminded people in the bathroom to wash
their hand but one person thought that
sign wasn't enough so they took matters
into their own hands by adding one
sticky note the sign went from please
wash your hands to please hide your
potato changing signs is no new thing
blogs have been covering signs that have
been changed by jokesters for years some
of the most popular sign changes have
included adding an X in front of men's
room signs to make the restroom look as
though it's specifically for X Men
others include adding hammertime
underneath stop signs so that they read
stop hammer time like the popular MC
Hammer song and drawing extra figures on
signs to make them explicit the only
thing that's left to wonder is where
people are going to hide their potatoes
government signs say what when you're a
teenager you take a test about road
signs so you know what they mean but
what about government side we barely
ever see those and it's for good reason
because it turns out that they are
pretty ridiculous
take this sign for instance what does it
mean if you set yourself on fire don't
run it's really not clear but it might
be the sign that makes the most sense
when you look at the other government
signs that are floating around because
the signs are so outdated it's hard to
determine what any of them actually want
you to do some suggest what you should
do if you suspect the specious behavior
to be occurring but how can you really
expect a stick figure sign to tell you
what to do in that circumstance others
tell you what to do in safety situations
those are a little easier to understand
than their suspicious counterparts but a
bit counterintuitive if we are on fire
you can bet we wouldn't be looking at a
sign to save us but despite not being
very useful it's the confusing nature of
the signs that make some absolutely
hilarious P here and end up on YouTube a
lot of people dream of being YouTube
stars the notoriety the free goodies the
fans what more could you want
but most people want to become famous
for a talent or some other
quality not for peeing in public that's
exactly what this sign is threatening
located near hotel and Meikle of Czech
Republic this sign is meant to deter
public urination by threatening to post
the perpetrators on YouTube we don't
know if this is an actual camera or if
it is meant as a scare tactic several
YouTube bloggers have promised to travel
to the Czech Republic and report their
findings public urination signs are
actually very popular in areas where
drunk people tend to calm the day this
is such a big problem that in some
countries the government decided to get
involved in Bangladesh for example anti
public urination signs are written all
over the city in Arabic the problem has
gotten so big in San Francisco that the
city opted to paint certain walls with
urine repellent paint someone should
have told them that all they had to do
was threaten to post the perpetrators
videos on YouTube because that would
definitely deter us how about you racist
Park most parks have been described as
beautiful serene and peaceful but this
park took on a whole new adjective China
isn't exactly known for its racial
diversity but when they were set to host
the 2008 Olympics in Beijing a lot of
the country's less racially sensitive
aspects were brought to light including
this sign that read racist Park this
sign was meant to introduce a park
dedicated to racial minorities it was a
prime example of how things can get lost
in translation olympic tourists laughed
and were amused by the slight
mistranslation but as china's spotlight
grew the government set out to correct
signs like this another example of a
sign that may have been missed
translated reads please don't cross any
railings lest suddenness happens the
sign was meant to stop people from
getting hit by a train but sudden as'
could really mean anything
signs like these are what attracted many
tourists to the racist park we have to
wonder if the area has lost out on any
revenue since its removal though these
signs may have been wildly inappropriate
they were definitely good for a nice
laugh and we'll be sad to see some of
them go don't pee standing up
restaurants typically have signs to let
you know which restroom is which
or to say that employees must wash hands
before returning to work but this sign
is probably the most hilarious of them
all just look at it it shows a picture
of a man trying to pee by leaning over
and putting his leg up we just have one
question why why would anyone think that
that was an appropriate way to use the
bathroom is that even comfortable what
led to this position we need to know the
sign goes on to tell people that this is
not the proper way to use the restroom
and shows a picture of the correct way
to relieve yourself the location of the
sign is unknown but we just have to know
why this place felt this sign was
necessary for people commonly getting
urine on the wall was there an influx of
people bending over to the side and
raising your legs to use the bathroom is
this a men's restroom or women lifting
their legs up someone please give us the
answers because this sign is just too
ridiculous to be true have you seen any
other outrageous bathroom signs floating
around that's it for the top ten
accidentally inappropriate signs that
will make you laugh know any that we
missed
let us know in the comments and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for
more fun videos like this one
[Music]